deux villes pour un même projet deux
ambiances ce mercredi 2 mai elle était
électrique devant la mairie de
coignières où devait se tenir le conseil
municipal finalement annulée en raison
des soucis de santé du maire jean-pierre
sevestre près de 200 personnes réunies
pour dire non à la création d'une
commune nouvelle
il regrette la soudaineté de l'annoncé
craignent une perte d'identité de
coignières au profit de maurepas je
tiens à l'identité de coignières de caen
aériens se sont mobilisés cet homme et
se mobiliseront encore si c'est
nécessaire pour quelques poignées rennes
ne soit pas rayer de la carte de la
france doit être mis devant le fait
accompli
c'est vraiment inadmissible on a
découvert en fait que on avait ce projet
de fusion qui n'était pas forcément
prévu donc ça nous a forcément
interpellé est amené à être curieux sur
le sujet à vouloir en savoir plus une
volonté de rapprochement annoncé le 9
avril dernier l'une des raisons avancées
pour ce projet faire face à la baisse de
la dgf les dotations de l'état avoir
toutes les clés capacité d'aborder les
différents dossiers les différents
projets que nous pouvons avoir notamment
les projets importants que nous avons
sur la ville de coignières sur les
années à venir
l'argument n'est pas recevable pour les
membres de l'opposition à coignières à
l'origine du rassemblement
car les finances de la commune sont
saines une fusion entraînerait pour eux
en revanche une forte augmentation des
impôts locaux
mais c'est dgf ne représentent que 7 %
de nos recettes de fonctionnement
donc c'est presque rien ici on a une
entreprise on a tout ça donc c'est
presque rien on peut totalement se
passer de la dgf c'est peut-être pas la
même situation à maurepas
une pétition pour demander la tenue d'un
référendum local sur le sujet a été
lancée elle aurait recueilli près de
1500 signatures à coignières ou le
projet ne passe pas a également pour
quelques élus de la majorité ils
seraient huit membres du groupe
majoritaire sur 17 à s'opposer à la
création d'une commune nouvelle avec
maurepas nous sommes quelques-uns
dans certains sont des membres du bureau
municipal avoir donné un avis très
défavorable à la fusion qui nous paraît
être un projet insuffisamment mur en
tout cas en l'état actuel des choses et
d'autre part c'est un c'est une fusion
qui est très déséquilibré au détriment
de notre commune au même moment ce
mercredi 2 mai se tenait le conseil
municipal à maurepas l'ambiance était
chaude et quelque peu après un échange
houleux avec le premier adjoint et
roanne le gall l'élu d'opposition ps
ismail havane a décidé de quitter
l'assemblée le conseil municipal a
finalement adopté le lancement de
l'étude concernant la création d'une
commune nouvelle avec coignières deux
élus n'ont pas pris part au vote dont
ismaïl à vannes 4 se sont abstenus pas
d'opposition un rapprochement avec
coignières sur le fond mais tout s'est
fait beaucoup trop vite
la communication a été très mal faite
c'est vraiment dommage parce qu'il y
avait certainement des choses à voir
ensemble de façon à ce que chacun soit
gagnant malgré l'approbation de maurepas
le dossier de fusion est pour le moment
stopper temps que le conseil municipal
de coignières n'aura pas valide et
également le lancement de l'étude
commune entre les deux villes une fois
que les études ont été votés du côté de
coignières on pourra aller lancer
ensuite engager la suite en tout cas
nous avons un calendrier nous souhaitons
poursuivre les réunions publiques et les
ateliers de travail et que les habitants
au moins avant l'été avant d'arriver au
vote avant la fin d'année
dans un communiqué distribué aux
habitants lors du rassemblement la
municipalité de coignières indique
qu'elle va organiser une concertation
collectif pour décider de la suite
donnée au projet de création d'une
commune nouvelle avec maurepas